you
[Music]
my name is Eduardo adeno de la rubia and
I am fortunate enough to be the
moderator for your panel this afternoon
evening I don't know what time zone I'm
in to be honest with you the goal of our
panel is to provide you the audience our
dear friends with an understanding of
how the data science leaders who have
been kind enough to share their time
with us today think about growth and
change in careers organisations and
responsibilities in data science and
we're very lucky to have them for just a
little bit about me I have been involved
in data science since before it had a
cool name like data science I've been
fortunate enough to hired my first
machine learning engineer in the late
90s and ever since then I've had the
incredible fortune of just supporting
great teams I'm currently a data science
leader in Instagram and so now I will be
introducing the panel to you immediately
to my left is Angela for the past 15
years she has helped me businesses
intelligently use data to make decisions
and trained others to do so and she
likes to see the impact of her work
making a difference every day her
thoughts and data science management
have been published in the Harvard
Business Review and The Wall Street
Journal and her projects as an immutable
contributor have gone on turn accolades
such as informs Edelman Award for
achievement in operations research and
the Management Sciences and the
Massachusetts innovation and technology
exchange award for big data and
analytics innovations she finds passion
in the craft and she's consistently
seeking improvements and better ways to
solve tough problems sorry say hello
Angela
next we have Hilary Parker she is a data
scientist on the styling recommendations
team it's stitch fix at stitch fix she
focuses on what sorts of data to collect
from clients in order to optimize
clothing recommendations as well as
building out prototypes of algorithms or
entirely new products based on new data
sources you also might know her as the
co-founder of the not so standard
deviations podcast which she does with
Roger Peng it's a bi-weekly data science
podcast that now has over half a million
downloads so everybody say hello to
Hillary next we have Karthik
so karthik rom is a research scientist
at the Berkeley Institute for data
science and the University of California
Museum of Paleontology
at the University of California Berkeley
Karthik is also the co-founder of the
our open side project lead of the u.s.
research software sustainability
Institute founding editor at the Journal
of open source software and has served
on the boards of various organizations
in this space including data carpentry
many labs libraries i/o and more so
everybody say hello to Karthik
and finally way down at the end right
there we have dr. Tracy - dr. teal is a
co-founder of data carpentry and now the
executive director of the carpenter ease
she received her PhD in computational
and neural systems from the California
Institute of Technology
was an NSF postdoctoral researcher in
biological informatics then an assistant
professor in microbiology at Michigan
State University while an associate
professor she saw researchers need for
effective data skills to effectively and
reproducibly conduct research and
co-founded data carpentry to scale data
training along with data production
she's involved in the open source
software
she's involved in the open source
software I didn't write that right and
reproducible research communities
including as an editor at the Journal
for open source software and a journal
for open source education Sarah say
hello to dr. Tracy
so when I agreed to do this panel I was
shocked at the breath that I was allowed
to have I really was not given any
constraints on what to talk about and
that's both really freeing and a little
terrifying and I thought actually back
to the previous panel that I was on at
this conference and I remembered that we
had so many questions from folks about
how to grow in data science you know
people like I want to get into data
science I'm a junior analyst I want to
become a data scientist people asking
about organizations and I decided let's
just do a panel entirely on growth so
I'm gonna kick it off with my first
question and so this is to the panel the
career paths in data science is
different for all of us what is the most
important lesson you've learned about
growing as a data scientist whether it
be your personal growth experience or
how you foster growth in others does
anyone want to take it to start I can I
can start so yeah I mean I think you're
totally right that careers in data
science I think we finally hired someone
who had a master's in data science
recently it's out of 120 people in the
data science or get stitch fix there's
one person who was like formally trained
and data science and so I think that
some of the most important things from
my perspective are being really nimble
with the tools that you're learning I
think that keeping like being very
flexible with tooling is super important
because in the various different jobs
you're gonna be tackling different
problems and there's really no space for
being a purist in terms of like the most
important thing is being able to get a
job done and and so being Epirus with
your tooling and trying to get every
problem into a very specific format just
isn't gonna happen
it's district specifically we have this
philosophy of kind of a full-stack data
scientist which is like obviously has
pros and cons but one of the big pros is
you end up having to create like scrappy
solutions for almost everything so like
learning how to create ETL from web
vlogs all the way to like front-end
applications so yeah just like kind of
having like a growth mindset and being
really flexible is super important and
then the other thing I'll say is that I
actually think some of them were I mean
I hate this term but kind of like the
softer skills are super important so
like especially like cultivating empathy
I think is really important for the job
and something that we don't talk about
very much but understanding users
understanding the people who are reading
the analyses you're putting out there I
mean that's in some ways the most
important part because you can do a
perfect data analysis but if the if
you're you know speaking a different
language than the person who's consuming
it you might as well have not done it
and so I think that's kind of a an
unsung hero of successful data science
work and so yeah a question for you
about that so I like that you were
talking about not being in not being a
purist how do you balance then or what
advice do you give for folks balancing
actually creating breadth in these in
the technologies they know with actually
having enough depth in any one thing and
there's gonna be you or anyone on the
panel yeah I'm not sure I have a great I
don't know if I have a great answer to
that but I mean certainly I'm obviously
I mean for people to know me I'm like
obviously really Adar and so I think
that learning one language really
fluently I know that's advice them give
something like kind of like a depth in
one language is very powerful and I
think I think a lot of the general
concepts from one language to another
translate really well so I found it
really effective to get a lot of depth
in one language and kind of a deep
understanding of like the work I'm doing
through that and then being willing to
be flexible and working these other
languages like you know we probably all
right sequel queries and we don't talk
about it very much I'm guessing yeah all
right now I do so you know there's a lot
of concepts I mean I learned sequel
BestBuy learning deep liar and then
being able to translate over so yeah
that's my answer
Angela you know I know you've managed
data science teams you've had Junior
data scientists what what advice do you
give to junior data scientists who want
to grow in their career I think I have
extreme respect for for junior data
scientists especially because being in
the sexiest profession of the 21st
century yes thank you for laughing yes I
think it made sense when when DJ Patil
wrote the article to have that
articulation of the profession but I
think it's created a sense that it's
really difficult to break into unless
you have a PhD unless you have two PhDs
unless you have two PhDs and a body of
work and three published books and a
collaboration with a Nobel laureate and
that's not true
I don't have a PhD and you stole my joke
but I've been doing data science before
it had a cool name or before I had heard
of said cool name and so I think and I
and I harp on this a lot I think being a
junior data scientist is a gift it's
it's a gift that you bring to any
organization and if you feel that
joining an organization is too difficult
because they're giving you a hard time
because of how junior you are I know not
everybody has this privilege but I would
make you consider strongly whether or
not you actually do want to join that
organization because what you bring is
you bring the ability to question Dogma
because you ideally by virtue of your
tenure in the discipline haven't been
indoctrinated yet into the dogma and so
you bring a breadth of ignorance and I
say that in the in the best possible way
you don't know what's supposed to be
done a certain way you don't know what
isn't allowed to be questioned anymore
and I think that's something that can be
extremely useful for
any organization and so I think that's
not something to hide or to shy away
from I think the ability to be
vulnerable and the ability to say I
don't know are actually extremely
valuable to me as a hiring manager I
actually have in my interviewing guide
questions that are impossible to be
answered or at least impossible to be
answered succeed succinctly
in the time allotted and that's because
the thing that I'm testing is whether
you have the humility to say I don't
know and whether you have the hubris to
say but I can figure it out and that's
the balance that that I think is is the
balance that I would recommend younger
folks in the discipline to try to strike
one of my favorite data science
executives was pushing back that his
team only wanted to hire senior data
scientists and he was like you really
need to stop doing that junior data
scientists are better they don't know
what is impossible yet and I really that
des strikes me the one thing that I'll
add I think these are all great answers
what do y'all think about ruthless
prioritization I think that as a junior
data scientist junior data scientists
oftentimes and product teams are sort of
like the target of product managers of
engineering managers and they're
thrashed in every which way do you have
any great advice that you give junior
data scientists on how to own their
communication style or ruthless
prioritization anyone yeah I I really
care about this question because I think
that so frequently as data scientists
were in these really reactive positions
especially as like a data analyst for a
product team especially if you're
probably embedded on the product team
and and I know like we talked a lot
about kind of building tools to enable
product managers and all of that and I
think that's important but I also think
that as a data scientist you you end up
thinking about the holistic product in
in unique ways and I actually think that
another way to solve that problem is to
take on some of the responsibilities
that OPM might traditionally take on
like in many ways I think that by
thinking holistically about that system
by thinking holistically about the
product you can really guide
decision-making and so I mean to your
point about ruthless prioritization and
I think that by taking a more proactive
like non defensive stance about really
solving problems can put you into a
place where you're really a genuine
partner with a product manager rather
than just kind of like they're the
person who crunches numbers for them and
obviously that's something like as you
get more senior that gets easier and
easier to do but that's one of the
things I really love about my job right
now is that I've built some really good
relationships with product managers
where I don't I don't feel like I'm kind
of just doing requests for them I really
feel like I'm guiding the product
development yeah and if I could add to
that I think one of the really important
things that a data scientist can do one
of the biggest sources of value is the
translational step is the ability to
articulate a business problem into a
quantitative answerable hypothesis and
then testing that in iterating and so
going back to your point about ruthless
prioritization the ability to define
that prioritization to understand what
is being asked and not perform a task of
a performing service to understand what
is the question formulating a path to
answer and if that path is not
appropriate having that dialogue with
the product management with senior
management with whomever it is that is
posing the business question or the
academic question and and in working
that muscle of that that translational
muscle I think that leads to to better
prioritization and also to be part of
the dialogue of that's fine you have
these 10 follow-ups
what doesn't get done because time is an
infinite and bringing that context in I
think is how I guide the the more junior
folks on my team
to react to that so I'm gonna move on to
the next question
that's all right so data science
organizations whether it be a small team
or a large multinational requires data
science leaders it's just a thing how do
you think about how you choose to either
become a lead yourself or how leadership
is different from I see work or how we
can do better to support leadership
amongst our ranks well so I really
appreciate the question around
leadership because that's definitely one
of my soap boxes I have quite a few but
I think that there is really like the
talk this morning where we know things
about education and we should apply the
things that we know about education when
we think about teaching people about
programming we know things about
leadership about what makes effective
leaders that value people and create
better products but our organization
that we have an opportunity to apply in
the data science space but that we're
not given opportunities to learn these
skills we're not necessarily given
opportunities to grow these skills and
so it is a real space where if we invest
in thinking about leadership more
strategically more implicitly that we
can grow better leaders in data science
and you know I think so many people have
the potential to be leaders that are
doing it in small ways like you don't
need to lead an organization to be a
leader if you're mentoring another
person you're a leader if you're you
know working on a small team you're a
leader so more people seeing themselves
as leaders and approaching it in a way
that values the people that they work
with I would love to see more of that
and I think that investing and that
would be really transformational in the
in the
sciencebase can you if you could go one
click more specific what would that
investment look like Wow my secret
project is that I'm not working on but I
would love to do so as the carpentry is
our model is to day workshops I would
love there to be something like a
leadership carpentry which is kind of a
two-day thing about I was talking to
Hillary before you know what are the
things that people don't know coming in
about project management about how to
support people how to be a mentor or
active listening facilitating a meeting
all like super exciting topics these are
so fun I love all these things but the
impact of doing things these things well
scales so significantly that it's just
one of those things that I think if we
invested in what how such broad impacts
so you know not everyone everyone
shouldn't be able to take a leadership
carpentry but also just understanding I
think an appreciation that you are a
leader and investing and learning more
about that looking to people who you see
leading in a way that you want to lead
talking to them about that how did they
get there was there philosophy what do
they think about being more intentional
and how we approach it and think about
it Karthik what do you think about the
difference between leadership and I see
work this is like a challenge that I
struggle with all the time so I have a
very non-traditional path into being a
data scientist or sort of a data science
organization leader and so for me I was
trained as like a traditional academic
and so trying to manage your team and
doing stuff to enable other people to
produce data science work is not
something that I'm trained to do and so
Tracy and I have all these conversations
about Jesus I'm a terrible manager like
how can I be better at this big and we
have like not just me and Tracy but a
handful of others talk about like how do
we make me better managers so this is
like a constant and ongoing struggle but
I think Tracy makes an excellent point
that a lot of people have potential
to be leaders and trying to identify
people and empower them is something
critical so I'm just figuring things out
as I go I don't quite know what I'm
really doing but it looks sometimes like
I know what I'm doing but at least with
some of these projects I'm one of the
things I think about is how do you get
more diverse people in the room and then
you actually find people that are
leaders and then you just give them more
responsibility and then they thrive and
then you sort of recognize people and we
just need to do a better job of that I
think following on you know what
Faline said this morning that wow people
know how to teach children and we're
just stumbling I think the same thing
applies to leadership and management I
think if we were more intentional yeah
because it is a discipline onto itself
and it is different and so a little
anecdote when I first became a somebody
who is responsible for somebody else's
ability to pay their bills which is how
I like to think about it it's a huge
responsibility it's it's a huge weight
on my shoulders to make sure that the
people that are actually individually
contributing are empowered because I'm
not my job is to multiply their
contribution and so when I had been
doing the work I had been mentoring I
had been project managing all of that
without without the label and the person
who was my supervisor at the time said
you know we want to make you the
official team lead and I went home and I
cried and I called up my then-boyfriend
my now husband and I'm on the phone in
tears saying do this I want to be in the
trenches but it's gonna be such a bad
thing to bow out to to say no thank you
I appreciate the vote of confidence but
no I'm gonna go back to the computer and
in hindsight I loved it I absolutely
loved it and so just to build on I don't
I don't think that everybody won
to be a leader but I in my gut know
everybody can be it's not a special
skill set it's not something that some
people are gifted with genetically the
ability to do no I think it is a skill
that is learn about and it's about
whether or not you derive the feeling of
accomplishment from it and if you do
great rocket and if you don't that's
fine too
but it isn't just if you are a great
individual contributor you're naturally
gonna be a great leader no they're
they're different skill sets and they're
both things that anyone with Drive can
learn and personally now years later I
look back and I love what I do today
even more because the way that I think
about it is I'm programming these these
folks because you can only pay somebody
to keep a seat warm you can't pay
somebody to want to solve a problem in
the best possible way that takes
mentorship that takes providing ability
that takes providing opportunities that
takes all sorts of things that are learn
about and that are incredibly empowering
because you see the work you see people
grow and you see people reach success
because of ways that you've you've
cleared the midfield and you've allowed
them to run their play oh let me just I
would just love to add I mean I totally
agree with everyone's talking I think we
are in a field that kind of lionize as I
see work and makes it I think that yeah
we we sort of self deprecating about
management where it's like oh I used to
be an icy worker and now I just like
answer emails or schedule meetings and I
think that's like it's reflective of the
fact that I think a lot of people myself
included in this field you're sort of
you likely came from a place where like
your kind of personal intelligence
personal productivity it was like you
know your self-worth and I think that it
actually takes a tremendous amount of
personal work to kind of break free free
of that and feel like you know there's
there's more to
my value then like being the smartest
person in a meeting and there's more to
success in this job than being like you
know the most productive coder and so I
think I I think in some other fields
that is like more of an understanding
than in technical roles and so I think
that like investing and kind of your
personal identity work for lack of a
better term and like kind of feeling
settled inside helps to kind of
understand like these multi-dimensional
facets of of being an effective leader
and so again I feel like that was kind
of a personal journey for me going from
kind of an academic setting where like
there's kind of one thing and it's being
smart into like this this role where
like partnerships so important
leadership like just it's just like a
more complete I don't know intersection
with the world it's a I'm kind of I'm
ecstatic that you talked about that
whenever I talked to folks about
transitioning from IC work to management
work it may not be the first question
but in the top three questions is well
but my skills are gonna atrophy like
that is sort of like the fear the fear
is that your skills are going to atrophy
and it's we not we don't do a great job
of understanding that a first and
foremost last time I checked like loops
are still loops like that hasn't changed
but unless y'all know something I don't
but note that actually like this gives
you this opportunity to develop these
incredibly rich skills have you all ever
encountered that where people like are
like oh I don't want to take on this
responsibility because I'm going to lose
something and have you ever like have
you provided any feedback to them about
what what you thought about that I'll
take a stab at this so I felt this way
all the time I still feel that way
sometimes
and so adding to what Hilary said
earlier part of transitioning to being
in a more of a leadership role is trying
to redefine what success means so for me
success is not being the smartest person
in the room or trying to be like the
best coder trying to write like the most
compact
like but if code possible I think of it
as like Angela does like having been in
this role for quite some time is how can
I enable people to do their best work
and how can I give them the resources to
do it
so that's sort of been like a slow
transition but it's like okay to be at
peace with it after some time and I
think it's okay to not want to be a
manager yes you can lead you can speak
at conferences and to find a tone of the
conversation and help spearhead the
evolution of the discipline without
having people whose time cards you
approve that's fine there's the
evolution of individual contribute
contribution is not management but I
don't think there's anything that should
stop anybody who wants to pursue it who
has the opportunity to do so a door
opens or a window opens but I think if
if you have any hesitation it's it's
worthwhile to explore that it's
worthwhile to explore whether that
hesitation is coming from a place of
insecurity and fear and an imposter
syndrome it's okay to wonder if you're
going for the management role because in
some circles it has more prestige if
you're fearing if you're coming away
from it because in our circles it has
perhaps less of a prestige because you
you our identities are so tied to the
the product of our code so I think all
of those are valid I don't think there's
any wrong way to explore this as long as
you have the knowledge that it's
perfectly doable and it's perfectly
valid to not want to do it either I love
that I'm gonna move on to the next
question if that's all right
so we've talked about ICS we've talked
about the transition of ICS to
leadership let's talk about
organizations for a second you know data
science organizations grow and change in
the organization that you see them grow
and change in an organization you've
seen growing change what is the most
important lesson you've learned about
what to do and what is the most
important thing that you've learned that
you should absolutely not
I'll kick off the big one that I've
learned is you don't hire data
scientists if you don't have data goofy
but but there are so many times that
I've seen people hire data scientists
they're like oh and we'll build a system
and we'll collect data and then you'll
get to do stuff with it but yeah you
know Carly Tracy what are things you've
learned to do or not to do in growing
organizations yeah so we're not a data
science organization we have data though
yeah I think that's a really interesting
question and I think it also depends a
little bit on the organization I mean
for us personally as a non-profit we
went from one person to a couple
organizations and mergers and that were
a team of about 10 and so I think one of
the things maybe not to do slash to do
is to think about where you want to be
when you're setting up your structures I
think some of the decisions made early
on or lock you into certain things
because they don't envision where you're
going and it's it's really hard to
envision that future sometimes at the
beginning but I guess what I say is sort
of all the time and my team laughs at me
is let's take a step back you know
forging ahead on this thing ok let's
take a step back you know where is it
that we want to go how can we not you
know over build it but give ourselves
when we're creating this thing the
flexibility for it to be something
bigger for it to scale and I think the
point is that you'll get it wrong a lot
but only by getting it wrong do you kind
of learn what to do next time yeah I
mean I think one thing that I've seen in
the organization's I've been a part of
is the importance of adapting
the business grows and so I think that a
couple years ago I was really into
blameless post-mortems and you know
reading a lot about them and talking
about them and I think that what I
really like about them is that it sets
up this paradigm for very explicit kind
of ROI discussions I mean I think you
know this is something that obviously
managers and leaders think about all the
time but I think that there are some
really important decisions in data work
especially about you know like for
example being the full-stack data
scientist is very appropriate for an
early stage startup where you need to
build scrappy solutions quickly and you
know you want to be able to function
independently but as you become a more
mature organization like that model sort
of becomes less and less feasible you
have like more of a higher you have a
higher standard for the algorithms you
put out as well as the you know
front-end experience for the clients or
the back-end experience you know you you
consider technical debt in a different
way and so I think just like having
having very explicit regroups about like
okay here was the trade-off we made for
like nimbleness versus kind of future
proofing and you know five years later
what does that look like I think that
that's something it's there's this great
paper about how machine learning is the
high interest credit card of technical
debt I think that's absolutely true and
so and the the paper goes in like
explains exactly why but in general
machine learning systems are very
complex there's a lot of hidden
assumptions in them and the technical
debt can scale really fast and in
invisible ways and so I think yeah just
like having these explicit check-ins
about what's appropriate for our work
right now is is super important I know
what else I think two other things now
that
is is one is investing in systems that
allow your team to work effectively
together and that's like physical
systems maybe that's project management
or communication strategies but also
around the values that you share as a
team and having a shared sense of what
that means and so not just what
communication channel you're going to
use about how are you going to
communicate with each other and that
shared sense makes I think all the work
a little bit easier and again is kind of
that thing that helps at this stage for
scaling I think like Keller is saying
knowing when to do that is always a
little challenging but it's usually
sooner than you think you should because
when you wait it gets a lot a lot harder
so it's that point where you like feel
the pain but not totally catastrophic
yet but even if it's totally
catastrophic you still can do it I'm
actually so don't hire data scientists
without data I'm actually gonna add
another one that I'm curious what y'all
think I think a big mistake I've seen in
organizations is over hiring what I've
seen is basically data scientists will
get hired and there isn't a clear
success criteria there isn't a clear
thing for them to do and they're just
sort of like brought into the
organization and told figure stuff out
have you ever experienced that and how
do you you know how do you think about
that problem in combating it in the
organizations you're in right now I
think I think one thing that's really
challenging and exciting about this
field is that in general like the the
product management of machine learning
systems is a new thing I mean I imagine
I think Facebook has some really
excellent kind of technical machine
learning PMS but I think you're kind of
not alone but there's not many folks
doing this well and so especially with
kind of smaller orgs I think that the
the data science can be a black box
you know I think that's kind of the
a common thread and so having having a
mature understanding of machine learning
within product management can be very
difficult and again kind of this this
thing I was alluding to earlier about
leadership I think that data scientists
can be really uniquely positioned to
guide machine learning product
development and by because they
understand the problem in a unique way
that probably most people in the org
don't understand it
and so I think that yes I have seen
teams kind of just pop up and it's like
hey have fun and they'll throw a junior
PM on the project and I think that's the
wrong thing I actually think you need a
pretty senior technical PM or you need
people data scientists who are acting
like like taking on some of the
responsibilities of product development
and thinking really creatively about
like what can we realistically solve so
yeah that's that's one of the ways that
I've seen like a failure and kind of
where I think the solution lies right if
it's okay with everyone I'll move on to
the fourth question yeah all right so
again we've talked about isyes we've
talked about connect on leaders we've
talked about organizations and all of
these around growth and I'm gonna talk
about responsibilities right our
responsibilities as data scientists are
significant as we've seen the ways that
data can be used or misused and I've
personally felt the weight of the
responsibility as a data professional
row I think that when I hired my first
ml and engineer in 1999 I don't think
that I had a great understanding of the
responsibilities that this new world
would create when you look forward what
are the principles by which you hope to
shape the policies and practices of data
science to assure that your work is
responsible oh I'll tie the answer to
this question with an addendum to the
last one which is one of the things that
I have learned not to do is when you're
when you have established that you have
a need you have established what the
success criterion is or the criteria are
and you're out and you're recruiting
and you're attracting talent and you've
you have a team perhaps you're at your
organization for for talent acquisition
and they've brought in several resumes
and now I have my resumes and I'm
looking at them the one thing that I
would say you shouldn't do is you should
not hire the best of the people you have
at hand or the best of the people that
you've interviewed I think one of the
things that we have a little bit is that
you introduce somebody they're extremely
smart they're personable or whatever
they would just be a bad fit that's not
a negative that's not something that is
a personal failure of them it's just not
a good fit and so I think going forward
part part part of that is having a
better group of people to choose from
better not in the personal qualities but
better as in how they fit what your
goals are and what the organization is
going to be and so that's the answer to
the last question don't do that and how
it fits to this is going forward I would
love to have organizations metabolize
the fact that it is so important to have
people working at your organization
people teaching at your academy who are
representative of the world because one
of the things that that we learn in data
science and one of the things that I'm
adamant about is that data isn't an
Hilary and I have had a conversation
about this data alone isn't ground truth
data are artifacts of systems they're
bread crumbs there's this amazing book
which I'm going to butcher I think it's
all tomorrow's but I'll tweet about it
it is in essence paleo artists imagining
what animals could look like so I don't
know if anybody has ever imagined a
t-rex
without the teeth glaring right like
every representation that we see has
that and so these folks who are trained
as paleo artists who are trained to
imagine what flesh and cartilage look
like on these these
excellent bones they reimagine what a
manatee looks like and its land fairing
or they imagine what a swan looks like
and it doesn't have a neck the way that
we know they do because these bones
aren't truth they're artifacts that we
have access to but they don't tell the
whole story and for you to be able to
ask better questions for you to be able
to imagine different futures for you to
be able to to allow for the fact that
that data might be only a partial truth
you need to part any people in your
organization who have experienced that
and who know to question that and who
know to question that things aren't what
you expect them to be they are what they
are and our job is to try to build
inference models and to try to
understand what that data is telling us
but I think it's a problem when we use
the data as the metric rather than as
the channel for what it is that we're
trying to to do so how I hope that
informs the theory and the practice of
the discipline is for us to be mindful
of the fact that we need lots of
perspectives to ask lots of different
questions so that we get a more
well-rounded understanding of what data
is telling us that's fantastic
I mean I'll jump in on that because I
actually share an office or one of my
offices I share with an actual t-rex
back someone I don't I don't remember
who this was off the top of my head but
assembled like Stegosaurus skeleton as
like a unicorn because they didn't have
a mental model of what it looked like
but but the real point is like having
good data science teams means having
very diverse data science teams people
that bring a lot of different ideas
together and also thinking a lot about
how to make your work just broadly
reproducible and effective and owning
your mistakes because we all make
mistakes and owning issues that happen
with data and then going back and
talking about things like blameless
post-mortems these are all things that
that are valuable and so
last year a handful of us got together
and started writing down what we think
are at the Kohl guidelines to be a good
data scientists so we captured all this
in manifesto
I think it's data science manifesto dorg
can't quite remember but I'll tweet it
out but I try to think about all these
things every time I try to assemble a
team for a project and the can July says
you don't just grab the best person out
of like list of CVS and just say like
you you think more about the team more
holistically first yeah it would I would
echo what Karthik said and was we saw
that question I said Karthik what's the
manifesto that you wrote because I think
it is having something to kind of tie
back every decision that you make so
know you're faced every day with
decisions that affect people right I
think that is one of the great things
and the terrifying things at the same
time you know what's your decision
what's your process like when you make
that decision
what's your foundation so something like
this manifesto or your personal values
or your company's values how do you
think about those things and in
everything that you do and I think it is
interesting as I give talks especially
in a public setting the question we get
most often is around the data ethics and
almost no one on the panel or anyone
speaking has anything to say about it so
thinking about what we would say and
being more intentional in communicating
that to the people who use the products
or the community at large and engaging
them being open to engaging them in that
conversation as well yeah I think all
very excellent points I'll add that on
there's Kathy O'Neil wrote a book called
weapons of mass destruction and I think
that one of the key takeaway she has is
that we should have kind of a data
science version of a Hippocratic oath
which is
that doctors take and I think that's a
great idea
I mean establishing kind of a
community-wide standard of the values
that we have I think is important
obviously it doesn't prevent like you
know not every doctor is necessarily
ethical but I think it's a step in the
right direction and then the other quick
thing I'll add is that frequently a
state of scientists kind of to all the
points about like diversity and having
people bring things up I think that
frequently again with the black box
machine learning thing a lot of times
you can't rely on other or other parts
of the organization necessarily
understanding the issues so taking that
responsibility to surface things and
explain the implications and yeah taking
ownership of that I think is really
important for data scientists yeah I'm
just gonna that ownership is critical a
product isn't gonna do it product is
trying to shape the future right yeah
engineering is trying to build it you
know at the end of the day we are the
ones who have this responsibility and I
would love to see a world in which chief
data officer zat which all the way from
chief data officer to the entry level
data scientist was keenly aware that
this was them their what they were the
bar they were the but where the buck
stops and I really hope that we're able
to continue that so we're almost running
out of time I think it's time for us to
take some questions from the audience
hopefully are the flying mics going to
be deployed I don't know what the plan
is exactly the flying mics so are there
any questions in the audience yeah I've
lights so I'm trusting that other folks
are going to see people and hand mics
off all right hi I'm curious what is the
most effective way you've seen product
management and data science work
together and actually accomplish things
because there always seems to be a
hierarchical shift depending on the
project and don't necessarily know how
it fits especially with you your
experience does anyone want to take I
mean I've got to take that if y'all have
a tank I prefer to hear it now I mean
I'm I'm very lucky right now in the data
science is one of our key competitive
advantages as stitch fix so you know
there's obviously other personal styling
services out there so it's kind of like
a freebie for me cuz I'm like oh yeah
just be a great partner and like come up
with ideas and but I think I mean I'm
just sort of repeating myself but I
think not assuming that your place is
just to crunch numbers and like thinking
much more broadly and systematically
about the problems that you can solve I
think that I mean product managers want
to put good products out there and so if
you work on solving that problem then I
think that they will respond to that or
at least that's been my experience and
so just like coming to the table
assuming again this takes confidence to
take personal development but kind of
assuming that you're a partner not
someone who's receiving tasks I think
that that can go a long way and they're
not obviously like actually partnering
and helping bring something to life I
think that's right one thing that I'll
add very tactically is whatever your
planning cycle is product has a roadmap
make sure data science also has a
roadmap yeah make sure that that roadmap
is correlated and complementary to the
product roadmap but not directly tied to
it and then make product see the value
in that roadmap because that allows you
to then have very very real talks when
product comes down and asks hard
questions about the trade-offs they're
going to be required I think that we as
data science organizations oftentimes
don't do that and I think it's a
critical thing to do yeah totally all
right next question we've talked about
this a little bit but I just want to
make it explicit what are common ways
that data scientists failed and if you
want to answer it in another direction
in your own careers if you've seen data
scientists fired or volunteered to leave
a team or a company what happened to
them
how did that happen to them and I don't
mean this in a morbid
I just believe that a lot of times we
learn about what works by learning about
how things break I'm gonna answer first
but I want a I've seen data scientists
fail by not saying no enough committing
to too many things being unable to
provide anything other than a cursory
analysis and then not having a
competitive value over a replacement
level sort of like Excel spreadsheet
that to me is the big one I'll add to
that ways that I have seen data
scientists fail is by assuming that the
product manager knows enough to ask the
question in the best way
not being collaborative and a partner in
helping refine the question so that the
ultimate product is the best version
that it could be and sometimes that
means it's a 180 from what was
originally imagined I think product
managers are very smart and they're very
good at product management they're not
necessarily really good at understanding
what's possible by sciencing on data and
that's where you come in as a data
scientist
to step in and to say no or to say yes
and what if I think having those
conversations are part and parcel of
what you get paid to do and and you're
not just somebody in charged with
delivering an output you're somebody in
charged with the success of a project of
a product of an organization so that's
the number one way that I have seen
failure and to answer your question what
has happened to that so in a previous
life I was leading a team for an
organization that was not data
scientific at its core but they were
expanding into the ative science and the
market took a turn and difficult
decisions had to be made and the entire
data science team got laid off my boss
me the people that worked for me all the
way down that whole branch just
chopped and the company's sort of
tightened in and focused on what had
been their bread and butter and this is
one thing about this community that that
is remarkable within six months
everybody had a fantastic job not a
backup job not a I got to do anything
out of the expiration because I got
bills but really great jobs that were
sourced through the community because
because they knew people who knew of
opportunities and who knew of good
opportunities and so I think that's part
of why we're all here it's to learn how
to use our studio and to become kick-ass
at it but to make connections and to
elevate the field I'll have the blonde
way that I've seen failure in data
science is like caring more about the
statistical method or the fancy model
carry more about that than about like
solving a problem for the business so
I've seen a lot of people building some
sort of fancy machine learning thing
that essentially was like a cool
intellectual project but wasn't actually
the person wasn't really tied in or
thinking about what the product needed
and like what what the customers of the
product needed what the what the
fundamental problem was that you were
solving and I think that's something
that is a impulse within the community
and we like to get together and talk
about fancy algorithms and fancy you
know data sources and whatever but
usually like many data science problems
can be solved with a pretty simple model
and so kind of like like letting go the
ego around that and really thinking
instead about about like you'll you will
have more impact if you think a lot more
about the product that you're working on
and a lot less about like kind of these
marginal gains by using slightly
different algorithms alright we have
time
like I guess this is a stupid thing
because there's a comment rolling the
question I apologize we only do
questions no no well let me paraphrase
something then there's a really famous
call about politicians that anyone who
grows up really really really really
wanting to be a politician should never
be allowed to be one and I think it's
the same for managers so Angela you're
you're okay because you don't want to be
a manager that's probably fine you're in
a good position and but I you know I
think there's also the Peter Principle
people grow you know that the
incompetent people grow into top
management positions
unless this ends with a question we're
gonna have a ruckus on our hands okay
hey thanks soft skills how do you manage
your mental health or what advice do you
have to manage mental health mental
health how do you manage your mental
health
yeah really any advice I have my advice
I have dogs I love an incredible wife
that supports me and every Saturday I
rent a room with a Jacuzzi in a sauna
for 90 minutes and I just hang out I'll
just say this is a great question and
burnout is a huge problem
with every single person that I know so
just being aware of burnout and doing
things like Eduardo does I better Tate I
do all kinds of things like him just to
like stay on the edge of burnout or push
myself back from burnout but one thing
you can do as a manager is actually be
aware of this if you've already
experienced this I can spot this in
people pretty easily so then I try to
enable them to like step back and then
refocus and things like that and
sometimes you're in an organization that
isn't as respectful of people's mental
health because of the culture and
everything and if you find yourself in
that role and it's incumbent upon you to
change that you can make a monetary
argument you can say that if people burn
out they're gonna leave
and the cost to replace them is too much
you can say that them being burned-out
means they're making suboptimal
decisions or they're making bad
decisions and they're harming the
product I mean there are ways to
articulate this so that you can do your
job of watching out for the people on
your team to make sure that they don't
have to raise their hand once they're
past their point of no return I think I
said it in my talk earlier if folks have
not read this chaos monkeys the story of
how Netflix has their systems
architected so that certain systems will
go offline on purpose and randomly to
ensure that there's resilience built-in
maternity leave vacation holidays are
people chaos monkeys and you have to
ensure that your team can survive if
somebody has an emergency if somebody
gets a scheduled vacation that they're
gonna go anyway and then something poops
out I mean those are important things to
build resiliency on the team and there
is a business rationale for them so if
you think that you working yourself to
death is in the benefit of the business
you've got it backwards and I have no
stomach for anybody who brings
themselves to the point of burnout
because they think that's what's
expected of them in my team it's not and
we just had year-end books closing and I
went through and I saw everybody who
hadn't taken their vacation and I went I
went and I talked to everything one of
them I was like why and what's going on
and so when is your next vacation and
when's that happening and you're gonna
turn your phone off you're gonna take a
SIM card out I don't want you available
because because otherwise other people
don't know to learn to work around that
absence that planned absence which is an
incredibly important business skill to
develop I would love to add like kind of
in this like financial you know there's
a reason I mean I have no doubt in my
mind whatsoever that the thing that has
helped my career the most
investing in my own kind of personal
emotional development I think you know
like jobs are deeply personal and you
end up exploring these parts of yourself
and your personality and your securities
and it's a unique lens that you see
yourself through and so yeah I you know
invest in my mental health I live a
design center here so sometimes it's
helpful but you know meditating and just
like generally being interested in the
human aspect of our job I think is again
like just just if you want to be a
better data scientist this has been the
thing that was most important to me I
just want to quickly add though I think
that there is an element of self care
that's more about shaming you into self
care so then you feel badly that you
haven't been taking care of yourself
which is like not the great cycle so
being kind to yourself that maybe you
haven't been taking care of yourself
you're not doing the seven things in the
magazine that they say you should do
like that's okay too
don't beat yourself up for not taking
care of yourself
but yeah it's a journey and figure it
out over time and I think you grow into
a role what you can handle next year is
not necessarily what you can handle
right now all right well I was gonna say
if you have anything you want to pitch
or if you have anything you want to say
we can go around if not I'm hiring you
are interested in data engineering in
data science if you're jr. if you're a
senior if you want to look at robot logs
if you don't want to look at robot logs
if you want to be a data steward we have
this awesome role that it used to be
called data hygienist and now it's
called data Stewart and the sole purpose
of this person is to look at provenance
and governance and ensure that everybody
who needs data has it and knows where to
go and if they don't how do we fix that
there's tons of really cool jobs so come
find me well I guess also Eustace is
hiring too
yeah yeah we're hiring it's a great
place to work and then also to pitch my
podcast I can I have a podcast called
not so standard deviations and we talked
a lot about kind of like the why of data
scientists the how of data science so
yeah would love to connect with
listeners and I'll just add that if
you're interested in talking about
challenges around leadership or running
open source teams or open source
projects or a data science teams or how
to transition from academia to data
science feel fair to email me or talk to
me yeah I think that they're actually
groups around those discussions is
important I think a lot of the things
that we talked about here talking about
them and knowing that their things is
valuable I guess if I was we're not
hiring I wish we were the nonprofit
status makes that our hiring rates a
little lower but if I'm gonna all pitch
if you want to support the idea of a
leadership carpentry a send me an email
all right well everybody thank you very
much for your time and thanks to our
panelists
[Applause]
[Music]